the leadership role is getting
incredibly more complex sometimes we get
so busy we forget to remember that we're
dealing with people as you become an
executive and you go higher and higher
up the ranks you're less and less aware
of what your behavior is triggering in
others and good and bad and so you
really kind of stopped growing IBD is a
program where executives have an
opportunity to develop their emotional
and social intelligence and become more
interpersonally skilled which is a
hallmark of good leaders it's a course
that my colleague David Bradford and I
co develop in response to an elective
course at the GSB that is perhaps the
most oversubscribed course in the MBA
program we are the only top business
school that has such program
interpersonal dynamics for high
performance executives it's a place to
learn to become interpersonally
effective what that means is not learn
how to make friends it means how to
create organizations and develop leaders
in a way that they are more able to
influence others inspire others motivate
others do I know myself do I know my
emotions am I able to express them in
appropriate way am i empathic people can
experiment with being more themselves
and finding out the outcome participants
find themselves stretched in an
unpredictable and different way than
they have been in other academic
settings most of the learning and IPD
takes place in these small groups called
t groups the t does not stand for
therapy it stands for training the idea
here is that I'm gonna learn best about
what makes me interpersonally effective
by engaging in interpersonal exchanges
with other people in real time one of
the real benefits of the T group is I
learned the impact of my behavior it's
risky to give feedback it's risky to
hear feedback but without risk there
can't be any real learning
tea groups at first were very
intimidating as the week went on I
started to see the value of the tea
group experience it became a place where
people did in fact think of it as a
laboratory testing ideas testing
thoughts you know challenging each other
and so I had several epiphanies during
the week that I don't think would have
occurred if it weren't for the tea group
experience what we most hear is people
willing to have conversations that they
thought they couldn't have ultimately
leadership is about mobilizing people
and it's hard to mobilize people who
don't feel connected to you who don't
trust you who don't believe in what
you're trying to mobilize them toward
who are not influenced by you we can
help executives learn more about
themselves and more about what that
means for the kind of culture or
environment that they're creating I
highly recommend this program to senior
leaders if you're able to be vulnerable
if you feel comfortable really
unlearning old things learning new
things and be completely dedicated to
becoming a more effective leader